a clark county school district teacher
receives a big honor
the choir director at green valley high
school is a semi-finalist for the 2021
grammy music
educator award 8 news 9 reporter kristen
drummond joins us live in the newsroom
now with more
on this national recognition kristen
sasha there were nearly 2
000 nominations submitted from all 50
states the recording academy and grammy
museum dwindled the list
down to 25 semi-finalists one of those
music teachers is from las vegas and get
this the only educator from nevada
up for this national award i'm just
honored
to have gone this far kim ritzer hits a
high note
in her career it was nominated for the
music educator grammy that is put
out by the grammy association a welcome
surprise for the choir director at green
valley high school the national award
recognizes teachers making a significant
and
lasting contribution to music education
while demonstrating a commitment to
keeping music education in schools
i do what i do because i love it i've
always wanted to teach choir that's
all i've ever wanted to do ritzer has
been teaching music for 31 years in the
clark county school district this is
what i see on my side
the pandemic made it her first
experience though only teaching online
we're still singing in a different way
but we're still singing and making music
adjusting to distance education while
continuing to build the choir program
known to perform around the country
we've sung at carnegie hall
and even saying back up for the rock and
roll band the rolling stones in 2013
during a concert in las vegas
here is ritzer with her class at a
rehearsal before the big day
[Music]
but her lessons and passion for music
education go beyond the classroom
she's shown thousands of students how to
find their voice and use it to make the
world a better place her principal and
student submitted testimonials hard work
kindness
bravery and enthusiasm are just a few of
the qualities
which mrs ritzer exudes on a daily basis
and helps to instill in all of us
all praise her ability to inspire the
next generation of singers
complimenting her dedication to keep the
music playing
even during challenging circumstances
just so you know
i can see everybody i've built a program
there that i'm very very proud of
ten finalists will be named next month
and a winner will be highlighted during
the 2021 grammy week events
along with receiving a ten thousand
dollar cash prize
and matching grant for their school's
program so our fingers are crossed for
her
sasha